if you want to become Mr Olympia one of
the challenges that you have you need to
beat the second place guy in order to be
able to come first so if you miss time
it and you are in the same era as Dorian
Yates or Arnold Schwarzenegger or Roddy
Coleman or Jay Cutler these Legends of
the sport you can still be unbelievably
good you can be world class you can be
better than world class you could be the
best in the world ever minus one you
could be the second best in the world
that's ever been in this Sport and if
you time it wrong you're always going to
be second and this is the problem of
using any external metric of success to
gauge your own self-worth that you are
inevitably Outsourcing your own sense of
self-worth you're crowdsourcing it to
the world around you and that's going to
lead to problems